from him and he ended up being
[Applause]
a four-car accident he's still not over
that's a horn give him the horn man
all right that's enough i'm comedian
ryan sickler and this is my stepson
derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
and your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh
no hold on look at it
look at this aloha whoa
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner's
permit
this is the true story this is the
craziest [ __ ] the first job i had was
the junkyard i worked there
starting in seventh grade we would work
seventh grade yeah hey he's breaking
we'd go up in seventh grade and on like
the weekends in the summers we would
clean up the yard like we would get all
the
scrap metal and old hubcaps aluminum
anything aluminum and we put them in
these different dumpsters and then
ship off the container so they can
recycle which is what my brother still
does now in delaware dude it's still
like primitive he took me in i got let
me see how you're melting these pallets
and stuff because they you ever see
those trucks go by with just the stacked
pallets that's what they do they melt
these
aluminum uh you said north right sorry
yeah okay into molds
i go where are you doing is it's like
right here and i walk in this room it's
like 2 000 degrees
and there's just this dumpster this
metal dumpster they're throwing this
[ __ ] in and it's molten lava shooting
out of the thing into a pan and they're
just stirring it with a big rock like
and you were iron thing and i go
this is it like you could trip and step
in that thing's like yeah that happened
and it happened to a guy he said
he said the dude slipped stepped in it
gone but it cauterized instantly what
does that mean that means the blood it
burned over the wound and stopped all
the bleeding and everything instantly
because it just
severed his leg and had to rush from the
hospital i was like jesus christ
and he figured out huh he lost his leg
well it didn't grow back
[Music]
i learned what cocaine was there
these guys would come in all hung over
and then kicked that door open but
like that i was like holy [ __ ] what's he
doing in there and i was like oh that's
okay watch where you're going
and one day we were
burning some uh old seats to burn the
material off to get to the metal that
was in them yeah
which is obviously not good to do look
at this guy yeah be careful with this
and um one day we're working up on the
hill and i just hear and he employed
like all a lot of the guys from our
soccer team and stuff yeah and i hear
this
what the hell is that i look over by
this car and there's a raccoon i swear
to god
and it's hopping like a kangaroo on all
four feet one eye is a solid blue and
one is solid white and this thing's got
rabies and we're like what the so we
start throwing rocks at it we're hitting
it and it's just like i'm like well
maybe it's protecting babies like i
don't know what it's doing but all of a
sudden
it charges us and i was like
man we ran like little babies
and i jumped into the back of the bed of
the truck and we drove i had my buddy
i'm like you drive just drive it down
the hill we drove down the hill
and we're like hey man there's a rabid
raccoon up there i don't know how many
other ones are up there i don't know
what's going on
stop where you looking look at the road
this [ __ ] customer
is there he's like i got it i got a gun
in the car he goes out and he grabs his
gun it's got a little red sighting on it
and we all all of us go up
put it right in its head i swear to god
that thing went down and got back up
like jason we're like
he just started
he started shooting until that clip was
going
oh my god it got up like a zombie
raccoon we couldn't believe it like this
[ __ ] thing so then
we were like we got to get rid of them
we were we had this fire going so we
just took the raccoon and threw it in
the fire and you guys eat it in the hell
no
but i swear to god it smelled just like
chicken it's if if this pandemic goes on
long enough and i can know i have a
raccoon without rabies i feel like
everybody says that about just other
animals they say it tastes like chicken
yeah but that's i'm not telling you what
it tastes like it smelled like chicken
[Music]
[Music]
you